[Music]
on this Monday night a global news
exclusive proceeds from Calgary
properties headed to Russia it provides
an enormous amount of Revenue which is
then used to bomb and murder ukrainians
plus how Canadian Parts ended up in
drones used by Russia to attack Ukraine
allegations of foreign meddling in
Canadian democracy I asked the Prime
Minister about the threat is China
becoming the enemy of the West
the pain of rising food prices when
relief could finally arrive
and he was all about kindness and
curiosity who are the people in your
neighborhoods
remembering Sesame Street's beloved Bob
McGrath and his connection to Canada
[Music]
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin with a global news exclusive about
a bankrupt Russian multi-millionaire and
the properties he owns in Calgary
they've been seized by the Alberta
Government and a court has now ordered
they be sold but the proceeds are
destined for a Russian bank that Canada
has placed on the sanctions list the
point of those sanctions is to [ __ ]
the finances of Russian President
Vladimir Putin and its Inner Circle so
they can no longer fund the war in
Ukraine but it's just simple reports
this case exposes how flimsy those
sanctions can be
these 10 Residential Properties in
Calgary including downtown condos and
East Village Suites will soon go up for
sale and the proceeds are poised to fall
into the hands of a Russian bank that's
accused of financing the war in Ukraine
it's the one of the biggest Russian
companies it's known worldwide as a
funder of the Russian war machine the
properties were purchased over the past
decade by a Moscow businessman who has
since fallen into debt so the Alberta
Government seized the properties and
ordered them sold with the expected
Millions going to pay his creditor a
luxembourg-based investment fund that's
allegedly controlled by Russia's gas
prom Bank the financial arm of Russian
State energy Giant Gas prom is accused
of supporting the war in Ukraine even
processing soldiers salaries and weapons
purchases it provides an enormous amount
of Revenue to the Russian state which is
then used to uh you know bomb and murder
ukrainians we will continue to tighten
the screws on anyone a betting this
illegal Invasion including influential
leaders of the state-owned Energy
company gas prom the Prime Minister
singled out the Russian energy giant
last fall while announcing a flurry of
sanctions
since the Invasion the Trudeau
government has levied more sanctions
than ever targeting more than 1500
people and entities the RCMP says it has
effectively Frozen more than 120 million
dollars in assets this National Security
Law expert calls that a drop in the
bucket we're really good at press
releases announcing the designation of
people which looks good and we have a
long way to go in terms of the capacity
to Monitor and enforce them the Calgary
case also highlights confusion within
Canada's business and legal communities
over when and how these sanctions should
be applied and so absent any sort of
clarification from the government of
Canada it really leaves Banks and
businesses and lawyers in limbo the
Alberta judge in this case acknowledged
that the proceeds will go to a company
that appears to be controlled by a
Russian bank which faces sanctions but
she also said that sanctions can't be
used as a way to avoid paying debt the
Trudeau government had previously
pledged to use frozen Russian assets to
help compensate Ukrainian War victims
but the funds in this case appear poised
to flow instead to Russia
Donna okay Jeff Semple thank you there
is new information tonight about
Canadian components being used in
iranian-made drones drones Russia is
using to attack Ukraine the so-called
Kamikaze drones are cheap to build and
easy to operate and have emerged as one
of the go-to weapons for both sides in
the war in Ukraine now a Ukrainian
investigation has found canadian-made
Parts in the drones used by Russia
despite a net of sanctions and trade
restrictions Mackenzie gray has the
details
[Music]
weapons in the Russian arson
the Shaheed 136 an unarmed Kamikaze
drone made by Iran
frequently deployed by Moscow at
military and civilian Targets in Ukraine
they fly low they're quite small they
were not as easily detectable and not as
easy to shoot down using Conventional
Weapons fearsome formidable and
featuring a Canadian connection akiv
Think Tank took apart one such drone
shot down by the Ukrainian military and
found an antenna component made by
Talisman Wireless based in Ottawa in a
statement the company said it's quote
painfully aware their parts are in
Iranian drones adding they absolutely do
not sell any of our products to Iran so
how do Canadian products end up being
used against our allies the Prime
Minister says Talisman is cooperating
with an investigation we have strict
export permits in place for sensitive
technology that are rigorously enforced
and that's why we're going to be
following up with this company Canada
has export sanctions on Iran but unlike
Finnish military products most component
parts like talismans antennas are just
pieces of a larger hole and don't
require Federal approval to be exported
allowing a and to get them elsewhere
remember a lot of these small component
cart parts could be easily sold to third
countries elsewhere in the world in
Africa or something like that for
totally legitimate purposes 30 other
western-made components were identified
in the deconstruction from countries
including Japan Germany and the United
States those parts have helped the
shahad 136 take off internationally at a
cost of about twenty five thousand
dollars per drone and a range of 2500
kilometers Russia can cheaply and
effectively dispatch drones into key
Ukrainian infrastructure the majority of
these airstrikes whether they're
missiles or Iranian drones or other
attacks or shelling are hitting
apartment buildings hospitals schools as
well as the energy infrastructure there
have been hundreds of Kamikaze drone
strikes across Ukraine but that slowed
dramatically in recent weeks the
Ukrainian military saying those drones
don't hold up well during the cold
Ukrainian winter Donna all right
Mackenzie gray thank you well with the
cost of so many things going up
especially groceries can Canadians are
already being careful with their budgets
that's going to have to continue
Canada's annual food price report
predicts next year is not going to be
any easier according to the report all
groceries which have already gone up 10
percent because of inflation are
expected to get even more expensive you
can also expect the cost of dining out
to increase by four to six percent and
as Ross Lord reports while the impact is
being felt by everyone the most
vulnerable are being hardest hit
Janice Berry has always tried to give to
others now she's conflicted about coming
to this Nova Scotia food bank for help
well there's two sides of it
there's the thank goodness I have the
help
when I need it and then there's shame
because I can't take care of myself
anymore it's not her fault her career as
a correctional officer was derailed by a
painful and now chronic kidney condition
then her husband died Janice currently
lives on long-term disability payments
less than half of her previous income if
I was getting by
but then when all the prices started
going up there's just you know you wait
till payday to go grocery shopping so
you have the money and then payday comes
and you pay your bills and you realize
you don't have the money
you just don't have it she's among a
record high number of Canadians turning
to food banks we have never had so many
new people in one week we had five today
new people we signed up and four
yesterday
and most of those people have not been
to a food bank before food bank managers
anticipate even more demand if Canada's
food price report is accurate 2023 you
won't uh won't be much of a break for
families who are struggling
unfortunately the report estimates a
family of four will spend more than
sixteen thousand dollars on food next
year one thousand dollars more than this
year it predicts overall food will cost
Canadians between five and seven percent
more researchers blame a wide range of
factors from climate change to fuel
costs to the war in Ukraine which made
this year's 10 percent increase in food
prices even higher than expected
Sylvanas charlebois says increases
should ease later in the year when
higher interest rates cause the economy
to slow down until then powerless
consumers are left with few options
other than shopping around for discounts
and using other forms of assistance if
necessary
well it means I can eat
it means I don't have to
not pay my power
or choose between
mortgage and food
painful decisions in difficult times
Ross Lord Global News Lower Sackville
Nova Scotia
Judgment Day for a top military officer
coming up a verdict in the sexual
assault case against Major General Danny
Forte
foreign
we've heard a great deal about foreign
interference in Canada's Democratic
process hostile covert efforts to
influence politicians and election
outcomes it's happening in other
countries too this summer the UK's
Security Agency MI5 and the American FBI
said the Chinese Communist party is the
biggest long-term threat to the West's
economic and National Security and this
fall Global News broke a series of
stories about allegations of Chinese
interference here in Canada I asked
prime minister Trudeau about this on
Friday during a year-end interview I
asked him why his government isn't being
more transparent about the threat here's
part of our Exchange
can I ask you if you've seen anything in
our reporting that is that is wrong are
we getting things wrong about the level
of interference because we have
information from thesis investigations
that the interference in Canada
allegedly involve payments through
intermediaries to a clandestine Network
that included candidates affiliated with
the Chinese Communist party that China
was placing agents inside the offices of
MPS
are you aware of that
now first of all it's really important
that journalists keep pushing and asking
questions and highlighting concerns
that's part of how our democracy works
well and it's really really important
um what I was and and people who
understand that I have to be very
deliberate when I talk about issues
around National Security and things that
we know to not compromise operations or
or various various things
but first of all ensuring that despite
all these uh these allegations and
Reporting people know that our election
Integrity held is pretty important
pretty basis and I would I would put
emphasis on that I never got in all the
briefings and all the serious briefings
I got I never got briefings on
candidates receiving money from China
and that so that's something that we
know
getting further into details we know
there is ongoing interference in Canada
we're going to continue to try and
counter it
and ultimately our election Integrity
held and we're going to continue to try
and be open and transparent as much as
we can on some fairly delicate National
Security issues
foreign interference is just one of the
topics I asked the Prime Minister about
the full interview including how the
government plans to help Canadians
tackle inflation and the rising cost of
living will air on December 25th right
here on global
the former head of Canada's covid-19
vaccine rollout says he is relieved
today Major General Danny Fortes says
his long military career was derailed by
an accusation of sexual assault that
dated back more than 30 years for attack
always maintained his innocence and
today a judge found him not guilty
tariya Israel was in the courtroom when
the verdict came down Daria
Donna Major General Danny Fox Says
today's ruling has Vindicated him but
that his legal battle is not over
claiming he is the victim of political
interference
surrounded by his family and legal team
repeated his denial that he sexually
assaulted a woman more than 30 years ago
when they were students at the Royal
Military College
this is a huge burden off our shoulders
my shoulders and and that of our of my
family this is one important step
in an ongoing process
to prove my innocence and recover my
reputation the woman testified
storm one night to find folkten
inappropriately touching her but judge
Richard Meredith found significant
contradictions in her testimony there is
no doubt the complainant was sexually
assaulted but the court cannot prove
Without A Reasonable Doubt the attacker
was fought 10. her lawyer says she's
still deciding whether to appeal the
woman's identity is shielded by a
publication ban she said she waited
until retirement to come forward because
she was afraid speaking out would
threaten her career the case costan his
job as head of Canada's vaccine rollout
he was let go last year and is now
fighting the dismissal in federal court
senior military leaders and political
decision makers
presume and acted as if I was guilty
says he has no plans on retiring from
the forces Forte is looking at all of
his legal options after what he calls a
failure of due process the Department of
Defense says it's now considering the
judge's findings as it relates to dnd's
own responsibilities and accountability
Donna all right Taria Israel and get no
Quebec thank you
Canada's first full-scale electric
vehicle manufacturing plant opened today
in Ontario the Prime Minister joined
Premier Doug Ford to talk about how the
partnership with GM can help Canada
become a global leader in the electric
vehicle industry we know we need to be
delivering those raw materials from
reliable friendly
environmentally protecting countries
like Canada and there's a huge amount of
interest in Asia and around the world at
Canada being part of how we move forward
as a world don't kid yourself I'm going
to be on the phone over the next week
with ahead of peer later head of UPS
head of FedEx I think FedEx is getting
some DHL thanking him for that other
businesses encouraging them to buy the
EVS right here from the Cami plan the
General Motors Cami production plant in
Ingersoll Ontario temporarily closed in
May to switch to producing electric
vehicles today the first 600
all-electric delivery Vans rolled off
the production line
education workers in Ontario have voted
to ratify a new four-year deal with the
provincial government the president of
the Canadian Union of public employees
says about 73 percent of its members who
voted were in favor this ends the
lengthy standoff between the two sides
education workers walked off the job for
two days last month after the provincial
government passed and then later
repealed legislation that allowed use of
the notwithstanding Clause to impose a
contract and ban strike action
ahead the status of Iran's morality
police as public pressure against the
regime Rose
[Music]
foreign
in the U.S a power outage affecting more
than 35 000 people is being investigated
by the FBI two substations in North
Carolina were severely damaged by
vandals using Firearms investigators say
the attack was intentional and targeted
but they have not discovered a motive
nor a suspect crews are working to
restore power they say it could take
days until then the area is under state
of emergency and a curfew is in place
overnight
the pressure keeps building on the
Iranian regime hundreds of people have
been killed in the unrest that erupted
in September after the death of Masa
amini she died in police custody
arrested for breaking hijab rules well
now protesters have called for a
three-day strike as a new form of
defiance an Iranian State media denies
reports the morality police have been
disbanded far NASA reports and a warning
some viewers might find the content
disturbing
for four decades they have brutally
enforced Iran's strict dress code once a
prominent presence Iran's morality
police haven't been seen as much since
protests broke out months ago this
weekend Iran's attorney general was
asked why his response the force is
being abolished his comments I believe
was were misinterpreted an Iranian
Canadian has started a social campaign
translating Farsi articles into English
to give the West some clarity into
what's happening in the region there's
no victory in this the laws the
mandatory hijab laws exist with or
without morality police according to
experts enforcement isn't changing it's
being renamed now it is called the
public safety footage it's the same
thing it's essentially a rebranding of
the name of this Force some point to the
comments being Lost in Translation
others say it's a response to the unrest
I think it may have even been
intentional because it came one day
ahead of a three-day general strike
shuttered shops and markets were a
prominent display across Iran today as a
massive active protest against the
government these same streets where
Iranians have been demonstrating after
the death of 22 year old Masa amini in
September three days after she was
detained by the morality police now
another voice is joining the anti-regime
chorus the outspoken niece of Iran's
supreme leader Ayatollah Khomeini
Iranian officials say 200 people have
died though human rights groups believe
that number is much higher and includes
as many as 60 children who are attending
protests including 10 year old Kian
pirfalak who according to his parents
was shot by Security Forces two weeks
ago the claims by the Attorney General
have not been confirmed by Iran's
government but a news agency in the
country reports the Revolutionary guard
said on Monday it will show no mercy to
rioters and thugs foreign ass or Global
News Washington
sing
sing a song for nearly half a century he
was a familiar face on a familiar Street
next remembering Bob McGrath foreign
[Music]
for generations of children he was a
teacher a friend and a familiar face on
television Bob McGrath who exuded
kindness and Curiosity has died at the
age of 90. he was one of the original
Sesame Street cast and made it his
life's work as Heather York's West
reports his generosity of spirit
extended to Charities here in Canada
all right gentlemen are you uh ready to
start your first lesson not so fast pop
for decades children came to know him as
music teacher Bob Johnson a resident of
the world's famous Sesame Street
one of the show's original cast members
Bob McGrath appeared on Sesame Street
for close to 50 years his face and voice
a treasured part of childhood memories
everywhere
[Music]
but across Canada McGrath was known for
his charity work as well
Bob wanted to do anything and everything
he could to make children's lives better
I've got five kids they're all very very
healthy McGrath helped host BC's variety
show of hearts and Saskatchewan's
telemerical telethons since the 1970s
helping to raise hundreds of millions of
dollars over the years to help kids
access special needs supports or medical
care we have children we had this gift
to through TV to to let people know that
he cared to in turn help them care you
always took something from him of how to
be a better person how to have human
kindness okay fluffy here's an F see if
you can play that all right listen
carefully
his family announced the actor's death
on social media Sunday Bob McGrath
beloved children's entertainer and
generous supporter of Canadian
Children's Charities was 90 years old
Heather York's West Global News
and that is global national for this
Monday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your
Canada is the light up the night display
at pilly's Island Methodist Church in
Newfoundland and Labrador we'd love to
see your festive Canada photo please
email it to viewers at
globalnational.com thanks for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow
bye-bye
[Music]